What's up, podcastaholics.
"Roll On" is back.
Adam Skolnick and I are inside your ear hole
infecting you with ideas, big and small.
Good to be here, good to see you, my friend.
Before we get into it, in addition,
as you may or may not know,
we also in the course of doing this show
conduct a little bit of show and tell.
We got some good ones for you on that front today.
And we round it all out by answering
some of the questions dropped on our voicemail,
which you can ring up at 424 235-4626.
If you happen to be watching
at http:\\www.youtube.com/richroll-
(laughs) That's very thorough.
Yes, just so there's no confusion,
please take a second to hit that subscribe button.
Maybe even click that notification bell or the like button.
If you're feeling frisky,
leave a comment below with your thoughts on audio.
You must also subscribe on Apple Podcasts or Spotify,
because that is the rule.
The rule of life.
How are you doing?
I'm doing good.
My right glute is a little twingy,
since you're asking.
Theragun.
(laughs) There's a Rich Roll
application for every problem in your life.
I've got a product for you, my friend.
Yeah, I have the Theragun.
What happened?
I don't know.
It's just like, I've had a piriformis
that is cranky for a long time
and sometimes it's more cranky than others.
And I think that's really what it is.
I think you know what it is
is that if I'm not doing my yoga
five days a week at least in the morning,
my body tells me-
You got to get
on that Goggins's stretching routine.
I do.
Of three hours a day.
Or however many hours it is.
I could be more Goggins.
There's no question about it.
We all could, there's a lot of room there.
A lot of room between where I am and Goggins.
I'm comfortably at the 38 to 40%.
That's pretty good, that's-
I'm not even sure I'm there,
actually.
You might be over-indexing
there a little bit.
(laughs) I might be.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Happy belated Earth Day, Rich.
Happy Earth Day yourself.
Every day is Earth Day.
That is the refrain, as trite as that may sound.
Yes, every day.
I was remiss.
I didn't post on Instagram my happy Earth Day.
Earth Day thoughts.
You didn't virtue signal
on Earth Day?
No, I didn't do that.
I'm feeling like a bad-
Missed opportunity.
A bad progressive, I guess.
You know what, I feel like-
Part of me is like, it's sort of like Valentine's Day.
It's like, oh, okay, we've made this social contract
that on this day, we all have to do X, Y, and Z.
And I don't know, man, I resist that.
You should.
I had forgotten that my wife and I
long ago before we were husband and wife,
or wife and husband is more apt.
Ooh, there's a virtue signal.
Yes, before we were wife and husband,
we had decided that we would ignore Valentine's Day.
And then I'd forgotten that,
and so I bought her a bunch of stuff
for Valentine's Day this year,
and then she didn't have anything for me.
And she's like, "We don't do Valentine's Day."
I'm like, "I knew that."
You broke the rule.
Your chivalry-
I got in trouble-
Fell on deaf ears.
For not knowing our rules
on Valentine's Day.
There you go.
It's confusing, this culture that we live in.
It is.
As a man
trying to make the right decisions and the right moves.
What else is going on?
I've been swimming more, which is good.
I got in three times the week before last,
and again this week, I've been swimming more,
or I guess last week, and it's been great.
The water's warming up a little bit.
Got a big swimrun challenge coming up in June.
Team Envol, Nicolas Ramires,
the guy who advises me on all things swimrun,
he got inspired by the 4x4x48
and saw that as this accessible challenge
for people who are interested in ultra to push themselves.
This is an accessible challenge
for people who are interested in swimrun.
It's much less demanding than 4x4x48.
It's over the course of June.
He's got teams in different locations.
And anyone can sign up and he can assign you a team.
You don't have to know anybody on your team.
And you don't have to-
The team can be virtual.
The team is virtual.
And basically, there's kids' teams if you're 10 and over,
and of course, mostly it's gonna be adults.
And all you have to do is a minimum
of 15 minute swimrun activity
with at least two swims and two runs.
So there's two transitions.
15-minute activity could be enough.
His wife is who, they have two young kids,`
his wife's just gonna do a three-kilometer swimrun
every day with a group of people in Stockholm.
So it doesn't have to be this huge thing.
And you get 10 points per activity
plus one point per kilometer,
or 1.25 point per kilometer if it's over 10K,
if one session is over 10.
And at the end of the month,
they're gonna tally it all up
and they're gonna decide who wins.
That's cool.
Where do you find out more about that
if people wanna sign up?
It's Team Envol, which is on Instagram,
and they've got a website.
E-N-V-O-L.
Yes.
Yeah.
And two euro, the signing up costs a little money,
and two euro of that's going to Sea Shepherd,
inspired by our discussion.
That's dope, I like that.
So it's a positive thing.
And part of the reason they're doing that
is that a lot of swimrun races are still being-
Are caught in the air.
Yeah, they're up in the air
or not happening because of COVID.
And so it's to kickstart people's training,
but also, during the month,
there's gonna be special days
where he spotlights swimrun organizers
where they have a specific challenge.
So like SwimRun Belgium might have a specific challenge
for people that you could take up or not.
It's up to you.
And there might be prizes associated with that.
What if you live somewhere where all the pools
are closed and you're landlocked?
So that's a good question.
So with all the pools are closed and you're landlocked?
Yeah.
That's very interesting.
You could-
I'm positing that
as a theoretical-
Well, the best thing
I can think of-
As a thought experiment.
So the world champion Desiree,
I have to look her up now 'cause I'm silly like that,
but she's one of the world champions on the women's side,
and she also does sometimes races with men
and so she does the mixed team stuff,
she's gonna be leading a group of mercenaries.
They're kind of the loner swimrun people.
So there's a guy that is being coached by Nicolas in Iran.
And he's the only swimrunner in Iran that Nicolas knows of.
That's pretty cool.
And so that guy
is gonna be on Desiree's team.
So people who are far out
that aren't connected to any swimrun community.
'Cause even though in LA,
there's not that many people involved,
but there are people around.
So he's got that group is gonna be,
Desiree's team is gonna be the mercenary group.
I feel like there's a New York Times assignment
where you could go to Iran
and do a story on the lone swimrun guy.
(Adam laughs)
If only I could just-
Nice country.
If I could just pitch you for my New York Times stories,
I'd have more of them.
Nobody's interested in that.
No, I think the Iran story would be good.
For someone like that to be like a new story,
he'd have to do well in a race, I think.
But there is, that's what Nico really wants is-
Does it train in the pool at the palace
that Bonnie talks about in her book?
Well, that's an amazing, that's Iraq.
Oh yeah.
But-
I just played my dumb American card.
No, no, no.
But I just think it's interesting.
Iran is a lot harder to get to than Iraq for Americans.
But I bet I could do it.
It's just a matter of getting permission,
especially if you're doing something
on culture like that, swimrun or sports.
So that's cool.
I would love to do a story on,
there was an open water swimmer
who was trying to stave off a civil war
or civil conflict in Tunisia.
And he wanted to swim from one part
of the country to the other,
and to do like the kind of swim diplomacy.
And so he did that this year.
That's pretty cool.
That's a cool story, too.
Yeah.
What else?
Oh, May 5th, there's a virtual run, "Running for Justice."
It's national day of awareness
for missing and murdered indigenous women and girls.
I don't know how many people are aware,
but there has been this epidemic
of murdered and missing indigenous women
in cities around the country,
but also in Native American nations on the reservations.
It's something well-known, it's been publicized.
There's been kind of even a movie about it.
This is a problem that's been ongoing for years and years.
And it's women who have kind of risen up
to try to get justice for these women,
or at least investigate the crimes.
And Jordan Daniel, who is an indigenous woman, local,
lives here in LA, was a collegiate level runner.
We talked about her once before.
And she was doing, I think 10,000,
5,000, 10,000K races on track.
And she ended up becoming a marathoner after college,
kind of dealing with eating disorder
during her college career.
And afterwards, kind of going through that recovery
and embracing longer distances as a way to pay tribute
to the women and girls who've gone missing.
That's cool.
And she ran
the Boston Marathon in war paint, symbolizing this cause.
Oh, wow.
And now, she is leading
this virtual run on May 5th.
So we'll link up the show notes.
Everyone can sign up.
There's a little bit of a fee, not too much.
And it's about raising awareness,
so you put it on your social media
and get more people aware of this epidemic.
Yeah, that's cool.
I like that, man.
Yeah, and she's phenomenal,
as a person and as an athlete.
Maybe we should get her on the podcast.
We should get her on the podcast.
Cool man.
Well, how are you rich?
What's going on?
(laughs) I'm doing pretty good.
I feel pretty refreshed
after a very hectic five days in Minneapolis,
which we're gonna talk about in a couple minutes.
Got a good ride in yesterday, like a 60-mile ride.
So I'm feeling progressively a little bit more fit
than I was maybe a month ago.
So that feels good, but a little bit
off my routine due to some travel.
But I did have one kind of a quick story
that's sort of a winner of the week
that I wanted to share up top here.
My boys, Tyler and Trapper, my stepsons,
and my nephew Hari just wrapped production
on their first album or EP, it's five songs.
Fantastic.
In a proper studio.
And just for context,
the boys have been playing music together,
these three guys, who created the theme song
for this podcast on the first day of the first episode.
It still remains since they were like six years old.
I mean, Julie put a guitar in Tyler's hands
when he could barely talk and it was all she wrote,
like it was clear like this was gonna be his thing.
Same thing with Trapper, with drums.
And we've been sort of waiting and waiting for them
to finally lay down some tracks in proper fashion.
Tyler along the way, his voice has developed,
it's so beautiful, and he's become
quite an extraordinary songwriter.
And they've been rehearsing
and rehearsing and rehearsing for months,
actually throughout the whole last year of the pandemic.
And Hari is-
Originally-
Their childhood friend?
Julie's brother's child.
Okay, cousin.
They'd been rehearsing for like a year.
And the original intent was that they were gonna have
their friend Chris from this band Grizzly Bear produced.
But Chris is in Spain.
Grizzly Bear is like
their favorite band.
Huge.
This is a huge opportunity for them.
Chris is in Spain, however,
and it was just becoming obvious
that it was gonna be too tricky
to do that in any meaningful way.
But they linked up with this other young producer
here in Hollywood and they just spent
all of last week at this studio called 64 Sound.
Julie and I went and visited
on the final evening of recording.
And it's this totally dope,
old school recording studio in Highland Park
that's got this incredible vibe.
It's owned by Pierre de Reeder,
who's the dude from Rilo Kiley.
And over the course of the history of this studio,
so many awesome bands have recorded there,
from X, Sleater-Kinney, Amanda Palmer, Ben Harper,
Death Cab For Cutie, Sia, Maroon 5,
so there's this beautiful history.
There's a cool studio tour video of 64 Sound.
I'll link that up in the description and the show notes
so you can kind of see what it looks like.
Amazing.
And they just have
this extraordinary experience.
They got to use an instrument
that was used by Elliott Smith, who they revere.
And they had some of their friends come in
and accompany them for some of the sessions,
including this guy, Harrison Whitford,
who's an extraordinary guitar player,
and is Phoebe Bridgers's guitarist.
Oh my God.
So Tyler and Trapper
kind of came up in the Phoebe Bridgers' extended universe.
They don't know her personally,
but they know a lot of the musicians
that are part of her ecosystem.
So that was really cool getting to hang out with Harrison.
So they laid down five songs.
And it was just, as a parent,
such a proud moment to see the,
not really the culmination, really the beginning
of so many years of time that these kids,
passion and time that these kids
have put into to their music
now turning into something
that they can share with the rest of the world.
And I have this moment,
the night before they were going
into their first studio session,
they were doing final rehearsals at the house,
the whole kitchen area, kitchen living area.
And our house was just musical instruments everywhere.
And they were playing some of the songs,
and I was sitting with Julie listening
and she just started tearing up.
'Cause we see them as the six- and seven-year-old,
eight-year-old, 10-year-olds that,
every time we would have a dinner party, they would play.
They play a couple songs by Nirvana
or Rage Against the Machine.
So now, they're men.
They're young men coming into their creative prime.
And it was just really cool to see.
So anyway, as a parent, that's a win to see that happening,
especially as somebody who spends a lot of time
talking about the importance
of pursuing what's meaningful to you.
And these guys have had extreme fidelity
to this idea of becoming professional musicians.
And now it's sort of, they're coming out
of the starting gate with that, which is great.
Props to the boys.
Do they have a name for the album yet?
No, and they don't even have a band name yet.
Oh God, I love that.
Yeah.
So they're still working on that.
Tyler wrote all the songs and he's lead vocals
and lead guitar and they played all the instruments
with the exception of some of the people
that came in to lay down accompanying tracks,
but Tyler doesn't want it to be Tyler Piatt.
He wants to have a proper band name,
but they just haven't landed on it yet.
He said he has five contending ideas,
but he wasn't willing to share any of them yet.
Piatt's a good band name.
You can tell him that.
I'm not telling him anything.
I'd say the working title is Tres Primos.
Is that what it is?
Three cousins.
I'll let them know.
Tres Primos.
Pretty happy to receive that.
We got a lot to talk about today,
but before we get into the big story,
which is gonna be all about my experience in Minneapolis,
why don't we drop in and do a segment
we're calling the Iron Cowboy ticker?
Iron Cowboy ticker.
That's right.
Which is also kind of a win of the week.
Today, it's the win of the week section two.
We've lots of wins of the week.
We do?
Yeah, there's more.
Okay.
Keep going.
The Iron Cowboy ticker.
He passed 50 Ironmans,
or quote-unquote Ironman distance triathlon.
Yeah, you can't call it an Ironman.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Iron distance triathlons.
He passed the 50 mark,
which was his own world record,
Guinness World Record, correct?
I don't know exactly how Guinness
defines all of this stuff.
I do know that he announced
that it was a world record once he completed his 51st.
Yep, and he had a big-
When he did the original 50,
obviously, those were all
in different states and he was traveling,
so now, it's all like very home-based.
But from what I understand or gather,
yeah, nobody has done more than 50 in a row.
Right, so his is 51.
So he had a big, I think it was his most
Forrest Gump setting yet where a lot of people
turned out to be part of the record
and they ran some of the marathon with them.
And then he gave a nice speech.
I saw that-
He gives a little speech
every evening when he concludes.
And he's amazingly kind of together and eloquent
dropping a few words of wisdom on whoever's remaining
at the late hour when they complete the marathon.
Did he just get more weather?
Did I see on today's Instagram or is that an old,
or is that an old-
I keep thinking-
Is that an old photo?
If he had just started this
like six weeks later,
it would be a much more pleasant experience.
They just cannot escape.
We're now essentially in May,
and they're still dealing with snow and sleet
and all this terrible stuff.
They could do early-
More power to them.
I guess that's why it's called
an adventure or a challenge, right?
So he's day 57?
Today, he's on day 57.
He does appear to be having some significant hip issues.
There was a bit of a limp
that I noticed in him the other day.
I saw him on the bike
using like a kind of ball roller thing
on his hip while he was riding.
So I know that's been bugging him.
But to date, every time he's had
some kind of setback from his swollen ankles
to whatever he's dealing-
He had like shin problem,
right?
Yeah, he just kind of powers
through it and seems to get somewhat past it,
which again I think is testament to the power
of the body to adapt to extreme circumstances.
And again, I said it before, I'll say it again,
this guy is so mentally strong.
Perhaps one of the most mentally strong people
you're ever gonna encounter.
My fear is that his mental strength
exceeds his physical strength,
but today, he's still cranking.
And it does feel like there's been
a little bit of a breakthrough,
like his mood seems to be really good,
and he's smiling a lot,
seems to be really engaged with the people
that show up and track miles with him.
And he shaved his beard.
He shaved his beard after 50.
I think that was the playoff
beard for 50.
One of the wingmen did, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, it's like,
whoa, what happened to the iron cad?
He looks like a totally different person.
Yeah, he looks polished now.
He's a polished cowboy.
But sending him love and wind in his sails.
It's like he was the bounty hunter on the planes,
and then he got recruited to the Texas Rangers
and they said, you could keep the hat, but you got to shave.
(laughs) I know.
Switching it up, man.
No, but I think he had like a real problem
with his ankle or shin or something.
And he found a brace and he was walking and using poles.
And then gradually, he was able to like,
if you looked at his marathon times
from like maybe marathon 30 to 45, full 50,
every day, he was getting a little bit quicker,
a little bit quicker, a little more running,
a little bit less walking.
And then the last couple days, I think he had-
The hip.
Yeah.
Now it's the hip.
Hits a little bit lower.
So it slowed him down.
Yeah, but not much.
But he's gotten over
and through these other things.
Amazing.
And he's on the backside
of this.
So much work remains to be done, but-
It's amazing.
It's gotta be an amazing
feeling to know that he's more than halfway there.
I'm in awe of the guy.
It's pretty crazy.
It is.
So everybody,
send him your love @ironcowboyjames on Instagram,
where he and his family and all his,
people that are supporting him have done an amazing job
at storytelling in real time-
No doubt.
This event as it unfolds.
I'm sure.
It's always like the first
Instagram Story that I watch every day to get caught up.
I mean, it's like a million little clips,
it's a lot, but you can just check in.
And there is something, we said this before,
there's something comforting.
I'm comforted by every day, waking up, I look at it,
and he's climbing out of the pool,
and I'm like, there he is, he's still doing it now.
(laughs) It's like clockwork.
Well, you were talking about long-term distance,
or long-term effects of these kinds of ultra outputs.
I was reading a story written
by an editor of mine in the New York Times,
Randy Archibald, about the ANVIL.
You're familiar with the ANVIL race-
No.
In Virginia?
He wrote this years ago, it was like 2016, I think.
It's a great piece.
It's hilarious and fun, and it's about five,
it's a quintuple Ironman,
but they also got cease and desist letters,
they couldn't use Ironman, but it's the same distance.
And you could either do the whole swim all at once,
then do the whole bike,
and then do the whole run with sleep deprivation.
Or you could do each one, one after, like day by day,
and then there's a cutoff time.
And so you got to choose.
And so he was there in Virginia, and it was all in this,
it's similar to the way James is doing it
because it's all in a-
Contained space.
But there's a thing
called the Deca that's similar to that,
where there's a loop, it's in England,
and they just go around in circles
like forever.
That's Thames, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so anyway,
in that story though, he referenced some study
that some doctors are out or scientists are out there
thinking that there is a long-term
heart health implications with ultra,
like their scar tissue or something around the heart.
Have you heard that before?
Yeah, I've heard that.
I've heard that.
Yeah, I think that there's truth to that.
It probably breaks down on an individual basis,
like who becomes susceptible to that kind of thing,
but certainly that's a risk.
It's a risk that James has willingly invited into his life,
and we need pioneers like this to show us what's possible.
When I did the EPIC5,
it was like, oh my God, you did five.
And now it's like, this guy's gonna do 100.
(Adam laughs)
It's like, once it's,
it's the same thing as Bannister
breaking the four-minute mark in a mile.
Once a barrier is broken, then the flood gate's open,
and everybody's perception of possibility gets elevated.
And that's kind of the story of the human race.
Yep, I'm with you.
I love seeing them out there doing it.
I just had never heard that about the heart stuff before.
Yeah, there's lots of studies on that kind of thing.
All right, well, we're gonna take a quick break.
And when we come back, we're gonna talk about Minneapolis
and other sundry topics.
Dateline Minneapolis.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast, and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change," featuring excerpts from,
poignant essays by, and glorious photography
of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous, artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared therein
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP
and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet Earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
All right, we're back.
Let's talk about Minneapolis.
Let's talk about it.
So the week of April 13,
I spent along with Blake and Jason in Minneapolis.
The idea of being to garner a tactile
kind of firsthand, boots on the ground experience
of what is actually transpiring there.
I said this in the introduction
to the Jeremiah Ellison episode
that went up earlier this week,
that it's easy to think you have a sense
of what's going on based upon the news that you consume
or the newspapers that you're reading
or the cable news channel that you're watching.
And it's something very different
to actually be there and sort of touch it, feel it,
to be present and immersed
in the events that are transpiring.
And I suspect you as an investigative journalist
have had this experience time and time again.
I'm not an investigative journalist.
It was something interesting and new
to take the podcast on the road.
Certainly, when I travel and go out of town,
I've traditionally brought a case
and do podcasts on the road, but this was different.
It was more event-inspired as opposed to just,
oh, I'm gonna be in this city giving a talk,
I might as well bag some podcasts along the way.
Right, right, right, this was part and parcel
to an event that has captivated the whole world in a way
because of the social justice implications.
And because we were all captive audience
to George Floyd's death and murder.
So it's crazy.
And my experience has been mostly
with under-reported stories,
but it's the same in the sense
that you drop into a place where you haven't been
and don't necessarily know the lay of the land,
and you have an objective and a limited amount of time
with which to get everything done.
And so there's an element of adrenaline
that's kind of always thrumming through you.
100%.
You feel like you can never relax
until you get stuff in the can.
And this was that times a thousand,
because you flip on the TV and it's just Minneapolis
24 hours a day on cable news, and you're there.
Right, you feel-
And it's all happening
around you.
and you wonder
what everyone else has recorded, like, how am I,
but the beautiful thing about you doing it
is that a photographer named Tom Stoddart
who I worked with earlier in my career,
he's a legend English photographer,
has been around for years and years.
And he was in Bosnian War and other places.
He's been a war photographer.
He's been the guy that is in Tony Blair's limo.
He's done it all in photography from the news perspective.
And when I was working in displaced people's camps
in Myanmar with him for a feature for Men's Health,
he said, "Some other people have done this story,
but you haven't done this story.
And so it's still important.
You do it for the first time.
It's still important."
And in this sense, it's even more so,
because first of all, you weren't just doing
the quippy kind of public radio story,
or even a 30-minute narrative,
you are doing deep in-depth interviews with people
who normally are just on the TV for about five minutes.
And so you bringing your perspective
and your skill as an interviewer, which I think,
and I've just wrote about this is, I think,
I don't think there's a parallel
for you as an interviewer out there in broadcasting,
and-
That's a heavy statement.
I appreciate that.
I've always believed that.
I've told you that before.
And so you'd come into this area with all this energy,
but for you bringing your perspective,
it's always gonna stay relevant.
So it's a really interesting challenge for you.
What drew you to mobilize the podcast in this direction?
'Cause it's new ground for you.
Yeah, it definitely was an opportunity
to get out of my comfort zone and play
with the format and try something new,
but I felt called to do it.
It felt important.
It felt like the right thing to do.
And I feel really good about the,
not just the content that we were able to gather
over the course of the week,
but the decision to do it in the first place.
And I think it's a direction that felt right for me.
How the audience processes it is none of my business,
that's up to them, but the rule for this show
has always been for me to follow my curiosity
and to try to have meaningful conversations that matter.
And this squarely falls into that category.
But it all came together in a very interesting way.
So I should probably recount that.
What happened was, my friend Brogan Graham,
who longtime listeners will remember
was on the podcast many years ago.
I think it was four years ago, 277,
something like that, episode 277.
Brogan is one of the co-founders of the November Project,
which is a global free fitness movement
that's now in countries all over the world.
He had been living in San Diego.
He relocated to Minneapolis a couple years ago.
And we've stayed in touch and been friends,
kind of internet friends.
And he reached out several weeks ago, a couple of weeks ago,
and was like, "Listen,
obviously, you know there's a lot
going on in this city right now.
I think it would be really interesting for you
to come here and get some interviews.
And I could help corral some interesting folks.
I know a lot of people in the city.
I'm pretty plugged in.
What do you think about that?"
And I immediately thought that that was a great idea.
And time is ticking pretty quickly
on how this story with the Chauvin trial was evolving.
So it was kind of a moment of clearing the calendar
and just jumping on it and getting out there.
And doing also in terms of getting out of my comfort zone,
when I've done podcasts on the road
in the past, it's just me.
But this time, it's like,
let's bring Blake, let's bring Jason,
let's do full production, quality video and audio.
We'll get a hotel room with a big room in it
and we can set up a set,
and we'll conduct as many interviews as we can.
But as we approached the day to depart to Minneapolis,
I was struggling to get, we did some research,
like who would be the people that we would wanna talk to?
Let's reach out to them.
And we were getting no responses.
And part of that is because I'm sure,
because everything in that city was obviously very tense,
but also kind of evolving moment to moment.
And there was a sense
that nobody could really commit to anything,
'cause who knows what's gonna happen the next day.
And the people that I was reaching out to
are also in high demand with the media
and the whole media universe
is now camped out in Minneapolis
trying to get people to interview.
So on some level, I was competing
with the networks for time and attention.
And if you're somebody,
if you're a civic leader in Minneapolis,
you have to gauge how you wanna invest your time.
Should I go on "Good Morning America"
or should I do "Rich Roll Podcast"?
So we get on the plane and it was very unclear
whether we were gonna be able to interview anybody.
But I know, and I know you know,
'cause we talked about this,
that when your heart is pure,
when your heart is true-
(laughs) I don't think
I've said that.
The universe
will conspire to support you.
I don't think
that's at all-
I know, a joke.
It's more like, you have to show up.
Yeah, you go to the story.
You show up,
and you're in 100% for the adventure
and whatever is going to unfold,
then magical things can happen.
But if you're like, well,
I don't have it all scheduled, so I'm not gonna go,
you're depriving yourself of that miracle.
100%.
And I've done this many times in the past.
So I knew to kind of trust that it would be okay.
And it ended up being more than okay.
We got incredible interviews
with a variety of super interesting people.
And once again, affirmed that idea
that sometimes you just have to show up.
Can I set the context a little bit here?
'Cause one of the people you interviewed
the first episode just came out today.
We're recording this on a Monday, and last night,
the Jeremiah Ellison episode just dropped.
But just to quickly set the stage,
you get out there a week
before the jury delivers their verdict.
And you're there right up until a couple days
before the verdict comes in,
or before the closing arguments.
Right, right, right.
So just to backtrack a moment,
Brogan deserves a ton of credit
for really being an incredible host
and helping to open up a bunch of doors.
I'm wearing this T-shirt, it says Zoom-Call Summer Camp.
Brogan sent this to me almost a year ago.
I love it, so I wanted to wear it today in honor of Brogan.
He also-
Well, Brogan
was kind of like your fixer, right?
Kind of, yeah, he's kind of a fixer.
He also gifted me with that moose
that you see in the center of the table there.
Amazing.
And he also-
Can we-
Created this
"Rich Roll Podcast" bingo card,
which I'm gonna get framed here for the studio,
that has basically all the words
that tend to recur on the podcast.
Give us a few.
Refuel, gut health,
John Joseph, Goggins, precipice.
He missed a few like unpack, new book-
Baked in.
Paradigm busting,
vegan, swimrun is on there.
Then it's got like, you can cut out
your little bingo chip-
I love it.
And the whole thing.
We gotta play bingo.
Anyway, Brogan is one in a million, he's one in a billion.
He's the kind of guy who goes out of his way
to do cool, creative things like that.
So shout out to Brogan.
He very much wants your job, so careful.
My job?
Yeah. (laughs)
We have-
I think I am gonna have him
come in and he's gonna be in the area
at some point in the not-too-distant future.
I'm gonna have him sit in and read some ads with me.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Have him sit in with us.
Yeah, it'll be good.
I'll just get pushed out of the way.
Right, but no, you're not getting pushed out.
Your job is secure, Adam.
(laughs) Is that Brogan the moose or the caribou?
The moose.
That's not him personally.
Oh, okay.
But to answer your question.
Yeah, so the Jeremiah Ellison episode just went up.
We were present through the culmination
of the defense presenting their case in the Chauvin trial.
So we left Saturday morning.
So Friday, the last day, the defense had rested,
and it was then headed to,
then Monday was closing arguments and then to the jury,
and we all know what happened with that.
Convicted on all three counts.
We should say-
Second degree murder, third degree-
Major.
Murder and manslaughter.
But there was this very palpable sense
that the city was on edge,
and had the verdict gone a different way,
I'm pretty confident that the city would have exploded.
Well, plus the day before you leave, or the night,
Dante Wright is killed.
Right, so that's on top of the whole thing.
So just to set the stage a little bit,
we arrive Tuesday night, I think.
We get there at like, I don't know, eight,
8:30 or something like that.
And we're staying in a hotel right in downtown.
We're driving through downtown to get to the hotel.
It's completely boarded up.
There's nothing open.
There's no people anywhere.
It was very eerie in that regard.
None of us had eaten dinner yet.
And there was a restaurant in the hotel.
The only vegan option was spaghetti.
And for $22, you could get an order of spaghetti
that was like the size of your fist.
I had two of those for $44,
and felt like I'd only eaten an appetizer
and I was starting to lose my mind.
I'm like, "We got to order more food."
But there were no delivery drivers,
and very few restaurants opened.
There was also the curfew, right?
So the curfew is at 10:00 p.m.
Restaurants weren't taking orders after nine,
but there was no drivers to deliver the food.
So we would go on DoorDash,
which is the main food delivery service in that area.
And it would allow you to place your order,
and it would look all good
and it would charge your credit card.
And then you'd get a pop-up saying,
we just canceled your order.
There's no drivers.
But they made sure to charge your credit card first.
Just in case.
So I did that
three times and racked up like $300 in food delivery.
That never showed up.
Finally, Jason, through his keen
telephone and interpersonal skills
cajoled a Chinese restaurant
into delivering us a bunch of food.
So it ended up being fine.
But for a moment there, I was like,
we're not gonna be able to eat.
So that was the first night.
Then after that, we started to get to work
and trying to pin down some people to interview.
And a bunch of the people finally did get back to us.
And we were able to lock down a bunch of interviews.
We ended up touring George Floyd Square,
which was an extraordinary experience.
And I said this in the podcast with Jeremiah,
but in many ways, defied my expectations
of what it would be in so many ways.
And in that is a powerful lesson or reminder
that when you think you understand something,
perhaps you don't understand it as well as you think you do.
Because I'd seen George Floyd Square
as all of us have on television a thousand times.
I formed in my mind what it would be like,
what it looked like, what the environment
surrounding it would be like,
and it was really none of those things.
We shot a bunch of video.
We're able to work with a couple local guys,
Jordan and Benny who did some portraits
and shot some video for us.
And we're gonna try to put together
a video out of that experience.
And it was really powerful and meaningful.
And also very meta, given that the eyes of the world
were kind of upon this city while we were there,
including the fact that on all day, Friday,
Dante Wright's entire family was in the lobby of the hotel.
Giving interviews.
So you'd see them on CNN,
you ride the elevator down
and there they all are with their lawyer.
And so it just felt meaningful to be there.
And I felt a responsibility
and a certain level of pressure to,
I don't wanna say get it right.
Brogan is always like, "You're not gonna get it right.
Release yourself from the pressure
of trying to get it right.
But at least be able to do service to these people
who were donating their time to share their story."
So it was very intense.
I was prepping most of the time with the exception
of kind of going out to George Floyd Square,
and it was just bang, bang, bang,
interview, interview, interview.
What hits you at George Floyd Square?
I know you've talked about it a little bit
on social media already,
and then in the podcast really eloquently,
but it was kind of in brief,
'cause you're talking to Jeremiah about his work.
What was it for you?
Because to me, when I look
at the photos and look at the video,
it almost is like it was a retrograde moment in America,
like it was a throwback a moment, a lynching on television.
And it almost looks that way.
It almost looks like what America used to look like
back when people couldn't eat it at the lunch counters.
It's kind of got that throwback retro look to it.
Well, it's in a neighborhood
that hasn't necessarily modernized or look like 2021,
so you can easily see it as 1965 in many ways.
The neighborhood itself is fairly residential.
Like I said with Jeremiah,
I expected it to be a much more urban
neighborhood than it was.
The space itself is much larger than I expected.
On the day that we were there, obviously,
your emotional experience of visiting George Floyd Square
is gonna be heavily dependent
upon what's happening in the square on that day.
And certainly, there are moments
where there's a lot of people there.
Sometimes it's celebratory and joyous.
On the day that we were there.
It was gray and kind of cold and drizzling.
There weren't that many people there.
It was in the middle of the afternoon.
And it just felt somber.
It was unbelievably quiet in the space.
And I was struck by the idea
that it's kind of like this living, breathing museum,
which is what I said the other day as well.
I didn't expect to be as moved by it as I was,
'cause I'd seen it so many times.
Like, all right, we're gonna go do this thing,
and then I was like very moved by what I saw.
And it's really only in part about George Floyd.
It's really about all of the,
like the legacy that led up to George Floyd
with all of the people who have died painted on the street.
There's a cemetery, sort of a mock cemetery
that they set up with gravestones
for all the people that have died.
And every little piece-
In Minneapolis
or elsewhere?
What's that?
In Minneapolis or overall?
I think it's for Minneapolis.
For Minneapolis.
Every piece of graffiti art,
every mural, every little artifact
that's placed is not policed,
but kind of managed by a community of people
that have a say in what, so you can't just go in there
and paint a mural or paint on the street.
It's not a, what do you call that, like a-
Public art space.
Yeah,
it is a public art space,
but there's a lot of intention
that goes into what's gonna happen there and what's not.
We had spent, and again, forgive me
for repeating what I talked about with Jeremiah,
but we had spent a good 45 minutes to an hour visiting.
Then as we're leaving, we encounter this group of people
who are all members of something called
the Agape Collective, I think it's called.
And this is the story that I wanna tell.
So maybe 10 of them, they're all wearing the same T-shirt.
And one of the guys says, "Hey, man,
what are you guys doing here?"
Not in a overly aggressive or threatening way,
but more like curiosity with a little bit of an edge.
Like, hey, state your purpose.
Tell us what you're all about.
Brogan's like, "Oh, I live here.
These are my friends.
They're from Los Angeles.
This is Rich.
He has a podcast.
And we're just here visiting
trying to understand what's,
get a better sense of what this is all about.
And the guy goes, "Oh, you have a podcast.
What's your podcast?"
"It's kind of a health and wellness bent.
But I talk to all kinds of interesting people."
And he's like, "Do you do social justice?"
And I said, "Yeah, a little bit.
It's not all the time, but that's why I'm here.
I'm here to have some conversations
with people about what's happening here."
And he goes, "Okay."
And then he looks at me and he goes,
"What does your podcast do?"
And I was like, what does my podcast do?
I was like, what is my,
and I literally was a deer in headlights.
I was like, what does your podcast do?
And I did not have an immediate answer for him.
I was like, he put me on the spot with that one.
Right, right, what does it do?
I kind of muttered through like,
well, blah, blah, blah,
I just, I try to empower people, whatever.
You said something, but inside,
you're like, that's not it.
Yeah, I was like,
I really should have an answer to that question.
And whether he knew it or not,
that was like the ultimate question.
Like that's a profound question.
What does your, and then the rest of the week,
Brogan was joking with me.
He's like, "Hey, Rich, what does your podcast do?
What does your podcast do?"
That's like Jules From "Pulp Fiction."
You almost just started walking near.
Yeah, I know.
That was it, that was it.
Exactly, I was like,
I give up.
Rich walks the Earth.
What an amazing, and so anyway,
we said enough to at least, I don't know if we,
we didn't win them over,
but sort of made them feel comfortable enough
that our intentions were pure.
And one of the women then
gave us this incredible tour of the space.
There's a greenhouse there where they're growing plants,
and walked us through all that different
kind of mini installations throughout the space.
And it was kind of an amazing experience.
It's kind of a reclaimed area
that now belongs to the community,
but in a very, not controlled,
but a very intentional kind of controlled way, right?
Very much so.
When you breach the border of it, there's a big sign saying,
now you're entering the free state of George Floyd.
And there's also these placards up that kind of state the,
I don't know if I wanna call them rules,
but like things to things to bear in mind
when you walk in here.
This is a place of grieving.
This is not for your Instagram moment.
This is a place that is that is somber.
They need that, though.
Please act accordingly,
essentially.
And just,
you realize how much thought
and intention has gone into this.
And yet, there is a debate over when to open
the businesses that are within the square.
Again, something I talked about with Jeremiah.
There's business owners that would like
to reopen their businesses,
but is that a good idea right now?
There's differing, conflicting opinions on that.
And then the gas station where they've removed
the pumps and now there's a fire pit,
and this is where the community leaders sit
and talk about the space and the issues
that had happened that day and whatever else is top of mind.
And it was cool.
It's almost like it will become a museum.
It'll be interesting to see what it looks like
in a year or five years from now.
The context in Minneapolis of all of this,
like George Floyd's death was to put it in,
we've all seen the video, and we've heard about,
we know about Chauvin and his background and it was murder,
but he was one of many people who have been abused
or killed by the Minneapolis Police Department.
They've had long time accusations of racism.
Black residents are more likely to be pulled over,
arrested, roughed up than White citizens.
They account for 20% of the city's population,
but made up more than 60% of the victims
of city police shootings from 2009 to 2019,
according to police data.
And Merrick Garland, the attorney general,
has just announced a complete investigation
into the Minneapolis police force
with the blessing of the chief, who is Black, we should say.
And so all that is the context for you being there.
That's the context for George Floyd Square
kind of blooming and becoming this place.
Yeah, the context is much broader than George Floyd.
And that's something that, look,
I realize like emotions run high around this.
In my opinion, Derek Chauvin
snuffing the life out of this guy on video,
it's like, this is not a hard case.
No.
And it is interesting
that there was such an exhale
and a sigh of relief when the verdict was announced.
Because it seems like this should be a no brainer,
and yet time and time again, we've seen it go the other way.
It was interesting when I posted a little clip,
little video clip of me and the guys
walking through George Floyd Square on Instagram last week,
it was for the most part well received,
but also met with not a small amount of derision
and what I would characterize as moral confusion.
If you ad hominem attacks a lot of what-about-ism
and this idea that to honor that space
and to appreciate the movement is somehow
to hoist George Floyd up as some kind of hero,
which really misses the point
and the main issue of the whole thing.
It was dispiriting on some regard to see that.
And I understand everybody's got
their own take and opinion on that.
And ultimately, I'd do it again.
I feel pretty good about being on the right side of history.
And like I said, I'm proud of the work that we've done.
And I think it is important.
And I talked to Brogan about this the other day.
There's this idea that yes, we all saw the verdict.
We watched it live here in the studio the other day.
There is this sense that we can exhale a sense of relief.
And I think it's okay to be happy about it for a minute.
There's this sense, like,
well, we can't be happy about this,
there's so much work that has to be done.
And that's certainly true.
Yeah.
But I think we can be grateful
that it turned out in that way
without it being some kind of a referendum
on the extent of the remaining work to be done.
Yeah, I think so.
I think that what you were referencing
with your Instagram post is like you had said
at the beginning of us talking about this
that we all think we know something,
and then you get there and there's a whole 'nother depth
to it that we hadn't really anticipated.
I think that when it comes to how polarized we are
with media choices or media silos or politics or whatever,
people are so sure of their opinion, more so than ever,
especially the less they know about it.
The less you know, the more sure you are of your opinion.
And I think that that's where a lot of that comes from.
And we're somehow calcified
with so little information into these little boxes.
And we do it to ourselves, and we're the product.
We've talked about it with technology.
And I think you're dealing with a little bit of that.
I think that's why it's so cool that you are wanting to flex
and kind of get that crust out of there,
because what we need is a certain level of unity
to accomplish big things, to make the world better.
That's what, to me, that's what you're after.
Yeah, flex might be the wrong word.
I went there with a lot of humility and appreciation
that even though I think I have a grip on these issues,
understanding that I was only touching the surface
of what was really going on.
And the spirit of the trip was to try to learn more
so that I could understand more comprehensively
the issues that are at play that I think,
look, Minneapolis is a test case.
Yes, it's about the current and future state of Minneapolis.
But to again, use the word referendum,
it's about the civil rights movement at large.
It's about where we stand on race as a country.
And it bodes, it is a statement
on where we're headed as a country.
And that's why the world was watching this 24 hours a day.
I think, you talk about, with Jeremiah in that episode,
about kind of the wins that the Minneapolis movement
for Black Lives Matter has had in terms of policing.
And I don't wanna step on that now.
People should check out that episode
'cause it's very interesting.
But for me, from looking at it,
when I look at the effects
of the Black Lives Matter movement this summer,
now we see two things.
One is the Biden election victory.
I think that's still directly tied to that.
I don't think you have the turnout you have
for Biden without Black Lives Matter.
I think that's a big win that is connected completely.
I think that was the first.
And I think the George Floyd, first of all,
having a murder case at all, and then the verdict.
I do think that you got to give credit to the BLM movement.
So for a movement that wasn't after anyone specific.
There was no civil rights law they were after.
There was no permission to go to school type of thing
that the civil rights period had, which are very simple,
like really easy to understand,
things they're trying to accomplish
that makes it easier for spectators, I guess,
or other people in the public
who are sympathetic and wanna know.
The BLM movement didn't have that.
So it was kind of like harder to understand for some people.
But now we have these two
really concrete things, in my opinion.
What do you think about that?
Well, it's harder to calculate progress
without some kind of touchdown moment.
So on some level, that's what this represented.
And progress is iterative.
Despite how much kind of revolutionary energy
you have around massive change,
history dictates that these changes happen pretty slow.
And as much as some people would like it
to move much more quickly,
we have to at least acknowledge
that it is moving in the right direction.
It is.
A couple of questions for you,
because you talk with Jeremiah
about kind of the defund the police language.
And I think that you should lay out,
I know Jeremiah does very well, but people are confused.
I think that anytime you question the police,
it's been a third rail in this country for so long.
It's like the military and the police.
You can't criticize the police.
You can't criticize the military.
It's like immediately a political third rail.
And that's what this movement was doing,
which is why people were like,
some people who were not sympathetic were pushing back.
But I think what the Columbus case showed,
I think the soldier that was pulled over,
the lieutenant that was pulled over in Virginia,
I think it was what that showed, maybe it was Maryland,
is that too often, first of all,
armed police don't have to show up for everything.
So when they talk about the activist,
talk about defund the police,
they are talking about moving money around
and having like you said, not a monopoly for public safety-
Well, it depends on who you talk to.
Like I said, defund the police
means different things to different people.
You can make the argument as Jeremiah does
that the provocative nature of that phrase
was what was necessary to produce
the conversations that lead to change.
The counter to that is that it's so inflammatory
to say that that it's unproductive.
Right, so my take on that would be like,
I think abolish the police is an unproductive phrase.
I think defund, I think you should, we're all grownups,
we should be able to listen to that
and figure out what that means.
'Cause for years, police forces
were funneled cash to militarize more and more.
And you'd see these, they have military Humvees
with their police department.
Some of that stuff is unnecessary.
And certainly what's unnecessary is to have
the lieutenant who wanted to drive a mile
to get into a well-lit gas station
immediately has guns pointed at them
and people shouting at them,
or George Floyd passing allegedly a fake bill.
There is no reason to get violent with someone like that.
Sure, or with Dante Wright.
Or Dante Wright.
In the middle of the Chauvin trial,
you're gonna shoot at Dante Wright driving away?
There's no reason to.
It's insanity, right?
You can follow him home and block the driveway.
Right, or just show up at his house tomorrow
if there's a warrant out for him,
but your job is to deescalate conflict,
but the problem is, so much of the training
that's bred into the police force
is that things can go haywire at any minute.
You've got to be ready at all times
for something terrible to happen.
And so you create a trigger-happy mindset,
because you're always thinking
that lethal force is gonna be directed at you.
And so that creates an anxiety or a fear, I suppose.
And I don't wanna get too deep into this,
because I'm certainly no expert on police training
or the entire issue as a whole.
But I think the relevant point that I would like to make
is that when you hear defund the police,
and Jeremiah being somebody
who's at the vanguard of that movement
and is kind of for better or worse,
been a prominent voice with respect to that issue,
when you actually sit down and talk to him,
what he says makes a lot of sense,
which is first to pose the question,
should police have a monopoly on public safety?
Which is a question I said to him,
I'd never really asked myself
that question or thought about it,
but when you think about it,
a sort of armed response to every 911 call
is certainly highly inappropriate.
There are probably the majority of those calls
that could be attended to without people with guns.
And we see this in other countries.
And we do need better training around deescalation.
We see it here in this country.
We see it in LA like-
Yeah,
but part of the kind of response is,
we don't need to defund the police.
We need to give them more money into training, maybe.
And we could talk about that.
I think the larger point is,
we need to reallocate resources
so they're going in the direction
of the kind of reform that we would like to see.
And that overall, the police force should be a tool
in a larger toolkit that includes
other public safety measures that are more appropriate
depending upon the circumstances.
100%.
'Cause I think what's also I don't hear
people talking about is the status quo.
It's not working for the police either,
in the sense that-
It'd be terrible
to be a cop right now.
Why would you,
right now or anytime there's lethal force involved,
everyone suffers from these things.
The repercussions.
One thing I was thinking about
when I was listening to Jeremiah is like,
look at this amazing family.
Keith Ellison, his father,
is the attorney general from Minnesota,
was a congressman for many terms is so empowered.
And this guy's an artist
who must've felt called to more service and decides,
and is really, has a great idea
of what it means to be an activist
and what it means to actually then
synthesize those demands into governing.
And he cares about both.
And he understands community building.
And he's as good a spokesman as you could ever find
from an activist point of view.
And now he's governing and understands
that's a different level.
And he's really on that,
not to put him in some politician box,
'cause he might be an artist in five years again,
but Barack Obama was a community organizer.
So when you see that kind of progression,
it's very exciting.
At the same time, there's this beautiful,
there's a beauty in these powerful families.
There's some sort of energy.
And it has nothing to do
with people's economic background necessarily,
or their ethnic background.
It's just some families have this
incredible energy running through it,
and that is an energy that I think
has to be treated with respect.
And at the same time, if you're a police officer
and you get into an altercation,
one moment could create a negative energy that runs through,
like the George Floyd family now
has to deal with this vacancy.
But the cops family has to deal with the fact
that he murdered George Floyd,
and the repercussions of all that.
That's what's so sad to me, the tragedy,
the tragic repercussions,
when you see what an incredible
purpose-driven family looks like.
That's what we all wanna be, right?
Yeah, certainly a call to service
is like woven into the DNA of that family.
Their mom was on the board
of the Department of Education, I believe.
Yeah, amazing.
Yeah.
So, anyway.
All right.
You guys saw the verdict here together,
and that was kind of like a cap
on the trip for you, wasn't it?
Yeah, we were back here
and working on the episode and it came on.
And well, first of all, Brogan FaceTimed me,
and he's like, "They're gonna announce
the verdict pretty soon."
So that was how I clued into it.
And we flipped on YouTube where it was streaming live
and just watched it until they announced it.
Amazing.
You think you'll do one of those trips again?
I'd like to.
Not for the sake of doing it,
but if it feels like the right thing to do.
It is interesting because the legacy of this show
is essentially evergreen conversations.
And this is something that is more news than that.
And we're releasing these now over a couple of weeks,
so there is a dated nature to it, I suppose,
but the conversations are really
about the ongoing conversation.
It's not about what's happening in the Derek Chauvin trial
or what's happening with Dante Wright.
It's about the larger issues at play
that are not going away.
That conversation continues.
And as everybody is fond of saying,
the work is just beginning and there's much to do.
Very cool.
It's almost like anytime there's a conflict,
you just wish that the people
that are called to deal with it
show up with this idea that I want the best interest
for everybody involved to be the outcome, including myself.
And so what is that?
And that would be a nice intention.
Now, I'm not a cop, but that would be a nice,
when I show up to do a job,
that's kind of where I try to come from.
And listen, I'm sure there's a huge number
of police officers that have that state of mind.
No doubt, and soldiers, 100%.
It's just, not everybody, and clearly.
And there's good reasons why people don't show up that way,
'cause maybe you have to be on guard,
and maybe there's something wrong with it,
but it seems like if we follow what you're saying,
what Jeremiah was saying in his podcast with you,
if you kind of divide up the tactics,
this you need an armed response for, this you don't,
maybe you have a better chance of getting there.
Yeah, well, we'll see what unfolds.
Cool.
All right.
Let's put a cap on that for now,
and let's move on to a little show and tell, shall we?
The show and tell segments.
Let's do it.
I got lots to show and tell today.
Your first show and tell is Ten Thousand, correct?
First up on show and tell
is the Ten Thousand distance short and kit.
Ten Thousand, long time sponsor of the podcast.
Shout out to Ten Thousand, I love those guys.
What's interesting about Ten Thousand
is that it's a relatively new brand
that really kind of found its mark in the gym
functional fitness kind of CrossFit world.
And they've been a great sponsor for,
I think over a year at this point, for quite some time.
And I love their gear, I love training in it.
Their stuff is really of the highest quality.
And they reached out to me many months ago
to share this plan that they had
to get into the running space in a meaningful way,
because their gear wasn't really
necessarily tailored for run-specific workouts.
And they just asked,
"Would you be interested in getting involved and helping?"
And because I love the brand
and I really like the people, the guys behind it,
I appreciate their incredible attention to detail
and their fidelity to the highest quality training gear,
that I was like, "Yes, I will jump on this.
What a cool opportunity."
So over the last several months in kind of stealth mode,
myself, along with some other ambassadors
that you might've heard of like Ryan Hall,
American record holder in the marathon.
Heard of him.
Turned like beast mode,
power lifting, bodybuilder guy.
It's unbelievable this guy's transformation,
but he's such a cool guy.
And obviously, nobody knows more
about running than Ryan Hall,
along with Robbie Balenger, our friend of the pod,
who ran across America and just set the FTK
that we talked about in Central Park.
Hakim Tafari who's been on the pod, friend of the pod.
We were all testing prototypes and giving 10,000 feedback.
We would do these Zoom calls.
I would use Zoom calls with 10,000.
There'd be like six
or eight people from their team on the call.
They were so receptive to all the kind of ideas
that I would have and they just continue to iterate.
They'd prototype after prototype after prototype,
super receptive, very humble about what they knew
and didn't know about running.
And they finally nailed it.
And they've created this short called the distance short.
I apologize, these are actually dirty,
'cause I ran in them the other day
and I haven't done laundry.
They don't smell bad.
They really crushed it.
It's a fantastic short.
It feels like a disappears when you're running.
The liner does not chafe.
That's my biggest beef with most running shorts,
even really great running shorts.
Like if I'm going out on a super long run, at some point,
I start to have to deal with like some chafing.
I've never had any chafing with this
material-
You don't use vaso?
Sometimes, like if I, sometimes I will,
but I was testing this without that,
'cause I wanted to see if there would be a hotspot with it,
but no hotspot, and I really love it.
I'm excited to have played a small part
in the creation of this product.
How long would your test runs be?
I'm not training super hard,
so 10, 13 miles, something like that.
I wasn't going out doing ultra runs
or anything like that, but Robbie was,
and he wore their gear for his central park FTK
and didn't have any issues whatsoever.
So yeah, I'm really proud to have played a part in this.
This is the tank top that they also created
as part of the run kit.
Look at that.
Nice blue, super nice material.
Everything that they do, like the stitching,
everything is so well thought out
and refreshing.
Fantastic.
And I told the guys that I wanted to share that today,
and they said, well, let's do a giveaway.
So they were kind enough to offer five full distance kits,
which is the short, the tank top, and a pair of socks.
To enter, to win one of these distance kits,
all you have to do is subscribe to the YouTube channel,
leave a comment below indicating
why you think you should be the recipient.
And we'll just pick five.
We'll reach out to you, get your address.
Once we select you, we'll message you
directly and get you the gear.
But if you would just like to bypass that and grab them,
you're certainly welcome to do that.
There's a link in the description below
or in the show notes.
And if you use the code richroll, you get a 15% discount.
Perfect.
One thing I did want to say
when I posted this on Instagram the other day,
there were some women who were like,
"What, no women's line?"
It is a men's apparel line.
So there's not much I can do about that.
It just is what it is.
But I am actively working with Ten Thousand
on some new stuff that I'm super excited about
that I can't really talk about right now.
So that's gonna be coming out later this year.
So cool stuff in the pipeline.
Very exciting.
Second thing I wanna share in show and tell
is this smart goggle from this company called FINIS,
which is swimwear apparel company.
And before I even do that, oh, you know what, David,
the goggles aren't even in here.
I think they're on my desk, could you just grab them?
Are you sure that they're not the invisible smart goggle?
These are not the invisible smart goggle.
But let me do a little backstory here,
'cause this is a good story.
So my friend John Mix, who's the founder of FINIS,
that's become like a very prominent
competitive swimwear and training device company,
he started this company,
I don't know exactly when he started it.
It was probably in the early to mid '90s.
There they are, thanks, David.
Not that big of a problem.
Yeah, yeah.
I met him through Pablo Morales,
the great Olympic champion Pablo Morales,
who I swam with at Stanford.
Then we did our final year at Cornell Law School together.
We lived together in Palo Alto
when we were studying for the bar exam.
And Pablo was like the initial investor
or one of the initial investors in FINIS.
They were kind of partners back in the early days.
And when I met John,
he was the first person to show me the monofin.
This is in '94, '95, something like that.
He had been, I guess the story goes
that he had been traveling in Europe,
and he happened upon a finswimming competition,
which he'd never heard of or seen anything like before.
He had been a swimmer himself,
and he's like, "I need to learn more
about what this monofin thing is."
And he got one and he brought one back,
or he brought a couple back,
and started playing around with them.
And he was sharing them with Pablo and myself
and a couple other swimmers.
And we would go down to the pool
at Stanford and play around with them.
And they were super fun and an incredible training aid,
because when you're doing it properly,
undulating the dolphin kick underwater with a monofin,
it works your abdominals and your lower back
like nothing else.
Were they heavy
or they're smaller than the freediving monofin?
So they come in all different sizes.
And in competitive finswimming,
there are different fins for different events.
And I'll get into that in a minute.
But there's like the sort of original models
are hand-built, tapered fiberglass with a double foot,
what do you call that?
Foot pocket.
Foot pockets that are extremely tight.
It's very difficult to get your feet in there.
And once they're in there, you're like locked in
and you become one with the fin
in a very kind of mermaid way.
And we were just having a blast
playing around with this thing at the pool
and getting a great workout along the way.
And as a swimmer, as I've said many times,
I was a benchwarmer at Stanford.
I was not putting points on the board.
But I had the opportunity
to train with all-
But you were
a Stanford swimmer.
These Olympians,
and I will say, if I was gonna toot my horn at all,
the one thing that I was,
and I think I still am pretty good at
is underwater dolphin kick.
Certainly, Pablo, Anthony Mosse, Sean Murphy, Jay Mortenson,
maybe a couple other guys on the team
were better than me at that, but I was right up there with,
not right up there but I was like kind of on the heels
of those guys when it came to that.
Was butterfly your main-
And this was at the age,
yeah, I was a butterfly swimmer.
And this was a period of time in the late 1980s
where swimming was just starting to figure out,
competitive swimmers were starting to figure out
how powerful the underwater dolphin kick was off the walls
and how you could swim faster underwater
with a proper dolphin than you could on the surface.
So there were backstrokers,
starting with Dave Berkoff at Harvard,
who would essentially swim
almost the entire 100-meter backstroke underwater,
'cause they could go so much faster.
And American and world records
were being broken using this technique.
Until FINA and USA Swimming said, hold on a second,
this is rewriting the entire thing.
We're not so sure this is the best way to do this.
So they ended up instituting a rule that said
you could not swim underwater dolphin kick
for more than 15 meters off each wall.
And that kind of changed the game.
But during this period of time where everybody
was pushing the limits with the dolphin kick,
we were experimenting with it on the team.
And I was always very strong in this regard.
So the monofin was like, where has this been my whole life?
I love this.
Maybe I should get into this finswimming thing.
And Pablo, myself, and a couple others along,
with John Mix's leadership started to learn more
about this world of competitive finswimming,
which for people that don't know,
there is an entire sport and subculture
that's quite robust in certain parts of Europe
and particularly in Russia and in parts of China where,
when you're coming up as a kid
and you show prowess in the pool,
they figure out right away, very early,
whether you're gonna be a fin swimmer
or a traditional competitive swimmer.
And certain kids get channeled into this finswimming world.
And there's a whole universe
of international finswimming competition,
where they have these meets, and you're in this monofin,
and you basically dive in off of a starting block
just like you would in traditional swimming.
And you swim underwater as fast as you can with this fin.
Everything from 50 meters-
And snorkle, right?
Yeah, so with some of the events.
Every event is different.
It's divided up into all these fascinating subcategories.
So if you're just swimming the 50 meters,
you don't need anything, because literally,
they cover the distance in like I don't know,
I should have looked up what the current
world record is for 50 meters, but it's like, I don't know,
12 seconds or 13 seconds or something like that.
And when these swimmers dive in with the fin,
this wave, it's like a tsunami, like a low,
like a two foot tsunami just moves down the 50-meter pool
and then just drenches all the officials
at the other end of the pool.
And it happens so quickly.
It's fascinating to watch.
There are other events where you use a snorkel.
So you have a center-mounted snorkel.
You dive in, and then you swim just below
the surface of the water, but the snorkel is above,
so you can breathe the entire time.
And you're in a streamlined position like this
with your hands out in front of you, undulating.
And then there are other events, longer events where,
I forget which one is apnea.
Is that where you have the snorkel
or is that where you have the tank?
No, apnea is breath hold.
So that's the 50, like when you just do the breath hold.
There are other ones where you use a tank.
You literally have an oxygen tank
that is wired to your mouth.
Really?
A thin long oxygen tank,
and you hold it out in front of you
like this in the streamline position.
I have my hands above my head for people that are listening.
And you'll swim 1,500 meters underwater
without ever breaking the surface,
breathing by dent of this oxygen tank.
You ready for the world record, 50 meters?
Oh, did you just look it up?
What is it?
15 seconds.
15 seconds, all right.
And 100 meters is 33.87.
So it's crazy.
When I discovered this, I was like,
how did I never know about this?
Because it's never really made its way to America.
So John brings the monofin back.
He introduces this device to a group of elite swimmers.
In short shrift, it becomes a go-to training device
for a lot of very elite competitive swimmers.
Most prominently, there's a swimmer called Misty Hyman,
who, she ended up winning
the 200-meter butterfly gold medal in Sydney.
And she was a devoted practitioner of using the monofin
in training and she had an unbelievable
underwater dolphin kick, the best in the world.
She's probably the most prominent example.
But that got John thinking about how
he could put together a team in the United States
to go to the world championships of finswimming.
I don't think I've ever told this story on the podcast,
but in, I think it was 1996,
the world championships in finswimming
was gonna be held in Hungary
in this town outside of Budapest called Dunaujvaros.
I'm sure I'm saying that wrong.
No, that's a great pronunciation.
Dunaujvaros.
I'm sure I'm saying it incorrectly.
It sounds good.
And he puts together this team.
There were probably like 10 or 12 of us.
The team included Jenny Thompson,
who between 1992 and 2004 won more Olympic medals
than any other female swimmer in history.
Pablo Morales, most winning swimmer in NCAA history,
won the gold in the 100 fly in Athens.
Your friend.
Misty Hyman,
who I just mentioned.
Chris Morgan, my friend, Chris Morgan,
who went on to become a very prominent swim coach.
He was the 2008 Olympic coach for Switzerland in Beijing.
He then went on to be assistant coach at Harvard.
He's doing other things in the swimming world now.
And then me, right?
I was sort of like piggybacked onto this crowd.
The would-be
lawyer waving his-
'Cause I was hanging
around Pablo.
Good dolphin kick.
John's like, "Yeah, you can come."
So in '96, we all go.
I'm like with these incredible Olympians.
We go to Hungary to compete in this meet,
but we don't know what we're doing at all.
These swimmers are unbelievable,
but they have no experience in finswimming,
which we soon learn is a very different discipline.
We were training together and trying to figure it out,
but it was like a hilarious,
"Bad News Bears"-type situation,
but with Olympians, with gold metal,
world record-setting Olympians.
Did they liked the fact that they were in beginner mode?
Was it-
No, 'cause it was fun.
There was no pressure.
And the United States had never attended one of these meets.
So we show up in Hungary, we go to this town,
which is kind of a communist relic,
a lot of these tall sort of housing facilities
that you could tell are from a bygone era.
And a very industrial town.
I think the steel mill was really the engine
for the economy in this part of the world.
But they have this beautiful natatorium.
We swim in this meet,
and I was like on the 4x200 relay.
They do relays like they do in swimming.
And just watching it was fascinating.
And meeting all of these athletes from all over the world.
I remember, there was one guy, the guy who,
I think he won the 50-meter apnea
was a dude from China who kind of was,
he was a big dude, kind of bulky, he had like a belly,
and he was smoking cigarettes outside the auditorium
in between sessions.
(laughs) Badass.
But he would dive in and like break
the world record in the 50 meters,
swimming in a way that none of us could.
And it was just really, it was just a wild, wild experience.
They're like, "Sir, your meet's about to start."
"Nah, I'll be fine."
But what's interesting,
and the reason I bring it up is that the legacy
of that experience is FINIS kind of popularizing,
through John, popularizing the monofin as a training device.
And most competitive swimmers use it
as one of the tools in their toolkit.
But at the same time,
finswimming has never caught on in the United States.
And you have some experience with this, right?
Because there's a crossover
between the finswimming world
and the freediving world.
Yes, so the monofin that was adopted by free divers
to go on constant way to get the records,
originally, they were just using bifins,
and then someone found the monofin and incorporated that.
And Alexey Molchanov was groomed
as a high-end national team level swimmer
from the time he's a little kid,
because his mother Natalia, the greatest freediver ever,
she was a competitive swimmer
for the first 24 years of her life.
Anyway, Alexi was kind of put
through the sports school in Russia.
And just like you said, he was divided,
put into the finswimming camp,
probably 'cause he was built with amazing powerful legs
and he had a great dolphin kick,
and they put him right in the finswimming.
And he did finswimming until he was 17
and immediately went to freediving from that.
And it gave him this advantage.
Now he's the deepest ever with a monofin.
Well, there's a reason, yeah.
Yeah, it's super interesting.
I can tell that when you're fit and you're using a monofin,
the feeling of moving through the water
that fast underwater is exhilarating.
It's crazy how fast you can go under water with it.
And there are, like I said,
there's different monofins
for different events and purposes.
So for the longer distances,
you're gonna have a very large,
broad, pliable monofin that has a lot of give in it.
And for like the 50-meter apnea,
it's gonna be a very stiff board.
And so I don't know what it's like now, but back then,
you could get a sort of commercially manufactured fin
that would just be a piece of fiberglass.
But there's real artistry in these people,
much like surfboards, creating the perfect fin
for that individual and for a specific distance or event,
that tapers, and there's all these little,
certain peccadilloes that the different athletes
would have with respect to their fins.
And so we were trading fins and trading T-shirts
with the Russians and the Chinese, and it was wild.
And as a swimmer who never made it to the level
where I was competing internationally,
it was like this cool way of tasting that
in a very low stakes environment for us.
'Cause we didn't win any medals or-
Were you still in law school?
This was, yeah, I was still, yeah, or maybe not.
I think it was right after I graduated.
Maybe it was, '94, I can't remember.
No, it was after law school, but shortly thereafter.
Fun.
As you get old,
I can't remember the timeline exactly.
Do you miss, how come you haven't,
you got to try freediving with the monofin, man.
You got to get your monofin back.
Well, listen, when I was in Malta,
I did a whole day of freediving breath training
with that guy, I can't remember his name.
The guy lives there, who's like a former world champion.
And then we went out to actually freedive,
and I could not get down below 12 or 15 feet
without my head feeling like it was
gonna explode.
You couldn't equalize
properly?
I could not equalize.
So I'm sure with discipline and training,
I could get past that.
But on that day,
which is the last time I tried it, I couldn't.
So I don't feel like I could really get
the full freediving experience
because of my inability to equalize.
Yeah, you just have to work on it a little bit.
You can easily get past it.
But I love the monofin.
All of which brings us to the show and tell,
which is that-
Yes, not a fin.
John, who then, I've just recounted
the early days of FINIS,
which was a company that literally
started with a monofin as its product
has now become this robust
competitive swimming apparel line,
has come out with a smart goggle.
This is what it looks like.
Look at that thing.
And John sent me one of the early,
before it's commercial,
it's not quite commercially available for you.
You can pre-order it, they're shipping in May.
But what's cool about it is it has a computer
that you can see that that fits in here.
You kind of push it in here and it clicks in.
And it's got a little optical,
I don't know what you would call that, lens there.
And in the corner for your left eye,
it provides output and data on your swim workout,
essentially real-time data to better understand
the patterns in your swim training.
It calculates split and time and distance.
You can see it very easily and read it pretty easily.
I was concerned because I wear glasses.
I'm pretty blind without them.
But I had no trouble reading it.
And it's amazing how it kind of knows,
if you're doing a set of hundreds,
it knows that if you sit on the wall
in between each hundred repeat
for more than like five seconds,
it's like, oh, okay, he's taking a break.
This is your split for the hundred.
And you don't really need a pace clock,
because it'll then count down
how much rest you want in between each one of those.
And then it all syncs up with this app
called the Ciye, C-I-Y-E app.
So your workouts upload there.
It integrates with Strava if you'd like that.
And what's cool and different about this smart goggle,
'cause there are other smart goggles out there
is that the actual technology, you can pull it out.
'Cause the goggle at some point it's gonna wear out.
The lens are gonna get scratched
and you're gonna break the mooring or whatever.
You just get another pair of goggles
and pop in the tech into that.
Okay.
Which is cool.
Perfect.
So I dig it.
I dig FINIS.
I feel allegiance to them because of my history
with John and the whole finswimming.
'Cause of your hungry days.
My hungry days.
It all comes in this beautiful box
and it's pretty easy to set up.
I set it up the other day and I dig it.
So another tool for the swimmers out there.
You know what I dig?
Your Rolodex.
You have a very impressive Rolodex, sir.
Listen, I'm 54, so I've lived a little bit of life
and I've met some people along the way.
Companies founders,
Minneapolis.
I love talking about-
Fixers.
finswimming, though.
I wish could remember, I'm gonna have to go back.
I have a photo album that I created from that experience
with pictures of a bunch of the athletes.
And I should have broken that out and reviewed it-
You know what?
If we're talking
about it today.
That's perfect
for show notes, baby.
Throw up with some pics
of Rich Roll '96.
Old photos from '96.
Anyway.
You know what, I forgot to point out,
on the smart goggle, and we'll put this in the show notes,
John was kind enough.
This is not a sponsored thing.
I just, I love John and I wanna support him.
But he was kind enough to offer a 15% discount
on these smart goggles, which is a $35 value.
If you use the code smartgogglerr at checkout,
and I'll put the link up, you can just go to FINIS,
but I'll put specific links up these goggles
in the description below, on YouTube,
and in the show notes on audio.
There you go.
Moving on.
What do we got?
Should we talk about this meatless meat, Ezra Klein,
New York times op-ed?
You know-
I feel like we've done a lot today,
but this is an article that Ezra penned up
that I believe ran in the Sunday Times
that I think deserves just a quick-
Did you know he was plant-based?
I did, yeah, I did.
He's been vegan for a little while at this point,
and he talks about it regularly on his podcast.
For those that don't know,
Ezra Klein founded Vox Media.
He did.
But now he's back with the New York Times.
His podcast is killing it,
and I think he's had Bruce Friedrich on.
He had, who else did he have on?
He's had a bunch of people on his show
that have been on this show
that are from the plant-based animal rights sector.
So he's definitely sensitive to this issue.
And I think this article did a good job
of explaining the complications
of our overdependence on meat and animal agriculture.
And I think it's interesting
that he has shouldered this mantle at the times,
because prior to Ezra being on staff there,
the only other person at the Times
who would occasionally talk
about this subject matter is Nicholas Kristof.
He would talk about the chicken industry
and things like that.
Yeah, in fact,
in this article-
Leah Garces-
They referenced the Costco chicken strips.
And that was all because of the work
of Leah Garces from Mercy For Animals.
He's been on the show, and has been on Ezra's show.
But the New York Times doesn't have a George Monbiot.
So Ezra is sort of fulfilling that.
He's not as staunch or,
Ezra's much more of a realist
as you will see if you read this article
about how to solve this problem,
but he does a great job of talking
about the implications of meat being on the rise,
the implications for future zoonotic diseases,
the problems related to antibiotic resistance,
the climate costs.
And in terms of the solution,
he's basically calling for, I think,
where he got criticized on this
is this call for government,
not government intervention,
but government budgeting
to invest in the plant-based sector.
Right, well, it was connected to,
he's basically saying,
I looked at the Biden plan for the climate stuff,
and there's nothing in there
involving agriculture and meat production.
Right, which is, let me just put a pin
in that for a second and interrupt you,
'cause I don't know if you saw this,
but unfolding on Twitter over the last 48 hours
is this idea that Joe Biden
is going to restrict people's meat eating.
And that caused this reaction in the Republican community,
including like Donald Trump Jr. saying,
"You're not prying the meat out of our hands,"
or "I'm gonna eat twice as much meat today."
I mean, really.
None of it
is rooted in reality.
Joe Biden never said that.
It's not factually correct in any way.
Anyway, I digress.
You're saying that the extreme right
is not factually correct?
(laughs) All right.
No, I'm just kidding.
But it was a thing
that just exploded on Twitter.
It just shows you, when you're trying
to have nuanced discussions with children,
it's very difficult,
because we're trying to have-
Now, now.
We're creating a welcome mat
for all people out-
That's true,
but when you're trying to have
a nuanced conversation about something
like meat and problems or police and problems,
there is a section of the public
that is not only gonna not listen,
but then to purposely use this issue to divide the country.
And it's unfortunate.
100%.
Yes.
I loved how he brought
the Good Food Institute into this discussion,
because Bruce, friend of the pod many times over,
who is the founder of Good Food Institute,
produced this wishlist calling for $2 billion in funding,
half of it for research and half of it
to set up a network of innovation centers.
And Ezra's basically saying
that he'd like Congress to actually dream bigger.
But the larger point being that it actually wouldn't,
in the grand scheme of the federal budget,
this isn't that much.
And it really wouldn't take all that much
to supercharge this industry,
at the moment when we could benefit
tremendously from investment in this sector.
So this sector meaning lab-grown meat?
Lab-grown and plant-based.
Okay, so both a little bit of plant-based,
a little bit lab grown meat.
And then the idea would be, you can't,
I think what Ezra is conceding
is he's not asking everyone to become vegan.
It's just not gonna happen.
People are gonna eat meat.
Right,
that's where he's realistic.
Right, and so the lab-grown meat part of it
is for people who are gonna eat meat.
And the reason I get torn sometimes
on some of this is that he even calls for,
there are small producers that are producing meat
that are less, they're not the CAFOs,
it's not causing the big problems,
and they're not as heartless with the animals.
However, obviously, when it comes to meat,
90% of the meat that's out there
in the market is coming from big corporations.
And so to replace a big corporation
with another corporation that's growing it in a lab,
I have less of a problem with that.
It's not like we're talking
about we're replacing mom and pops
with all of a sudden this big company
that's gonna suck up all the dollars
like Amazon or Walmart has done with mom and pop stores.
That's not what's happening here.
It's big companies that are involved,
and they typically, when it comes to animal feed, CAFOs,
they basically pay a pittance to the farmer
that doesn't even own the animal,
just to feed them as quickly as possible.
And they barely pay them.
And the farmers are on leases and a lot of the times,
they have financial problem.
Yes, it's an indentured
servitude model where they're servicing debt now.
And the idea of the bucolic family farm,
certainly, there are some of those,
but that's not how we're feeding the world or America.
Exactly.
So I think the idea,
the counterpoint to this is that this is not the solution.
Regenerative agriculture is the solution.
And there's some truth in that, but at the same time,
it's a bit of a red herring.
Because although it's certainly better
if you're gonna eat meat to make sure
that your meat comes from a farm
that is dedicated to regenerating the soil,
that takes care of their animals
and provides a range-free life to them
and grass-fed and all the like,
like the Chester's "Biggest Little Farm" and all of that.
The problem is that you can't scale that
to meet the level of demand
that the world is requiring
at the moment.
That's right.
There just isn't enough land.
All of our land is already devoted to these animals.
And to the extent that we pivot away from that,
people don't understand how much
of industrialized plant agriculture,
it's something like 75% of that is going to livestock feed.
It's going to the animals.
So we need a better solution.
We need all solutions on the table.
Plant-based, lab-grown.
It's gonna be really interesting to see how this develops.
It's developing rapidly and quickly.
Just, Josh Tetrick at Just is now serving lab meat overseas.
I think in Singapore,
they're serving it in restaurants right now.
There's still some issues around getting it
to a certain scale so they can drive the cost down.
Because ultimately, to win this war,
whether it's plant-based meat or lab-grown meat,
they're calling it cultured meat now,
that's their favorite term at the moment.
It keeps changing.
First. it was cell-based meat.
It's cultured meat now.
You have to create a product that tastes
as good or better than what currently exists.
And it has to be at the same price point
or cheaper than what exists right now.
It's the only way that you win.
And I think we're moving
in that direction and that's exciting.
And I celebrate Ezra for shining
the New York Times' spotlight onto this.
Well, in that regard, you do need government subsidies,
because government subsidizes GMO corn
and government subsidizes these industries.
But I don't think we're talking about subsidies here.
We're talking about a level of investment in research,
which is different.
When I hear subsidy,
I bristle.
Fair enough.
I retract.
What we need to do
is be done with the subsidies
that are propping up corn and all these other products
that are creating cheap commodified
processed foods that are making people sick.
It's a great story, because he gets into so much
kind of setting up the problem with animal agriculture
and even getting into like the,
so much of the way capitalism works
just by nature is that all these ripple effects that are,
sometimes they're positive, but oftentimes they're negative,
all these negative ripple effects.
The producer of a product,
whether it's a piece of single use plastic or steak,
they don't have to pay for all that.
The government picks up that tab,
or the public has to deal with the ramifications.
And so if you actually pay the true real world costs,
including cleanup for your messy CAFO to have the steak,
the steak wouldn't cost 10 bucks, it would cost 50 bucks.
Right, and a Big Mac would cost
I think $7 when you do the math on that,
if you excise out the extent to which it's subsidized.
So he gets into that.
It's a really good piece, I liked it.
Rich, I have a question for you.
What's that?
Would you eat a lab-grown, excuse me, cultured steak?
I don't know.
I've been asked that before.
I haven't decided yet.
You don't have to decide.
I need to know.
I'm on a wait-and-see approach.
I suppose I would, just out of pure curiosity.
But it's not like I'm waiting for that to happen
or I can't wait for that to happen.
I've been eating plant-based for so long.
I don't have a taste for that anymore.
So it's not like I crave it.
I don't need it.
And it's not all of a sudden
like steak will be good for you, right?
No, but certainly, when people say, the ick factor.
Like, oh, this is brewed, what is this, it's freak food.
But when you really look at the way
animals are raised and slaughtered,
the manner in which they end up at your grocery store,
they're pumped full of antibiotics.
They're basically living in their own feces.
They're brewing with disease or, that's what's gross.
That's the real problem.
That's the ick factor.
So to the extent that we can produce meat
without the suffering
and without all of these upstream problems,
certainly, that's gonna be more palatable,
but there's gonna be an arc
in getting culture to cotton onto that.
There'll be an adoption period, I suppose.
And I think that we'll be better off for it,
because even though it's not something
that I necessarily find myself looking forward to,
I, like Ezra, acknowledge the reality
that not everyone's gonna get struck plant-based or vegan.
I did.
And I always enjoy it when people step
into this lifestyle that has done so much for me,
and I can't evangelize it enough,
but I'm realistic in that I'm not gonna,
there's a lot of people that aren't gonna be convinced.
You know who's been convinced and is now vegan?
You?
No, Mookie Betts.
Who's Mooky Betts?
Rich Roll.
Is he an athlete?
He is the starting center-
I follow finswimming.
He's the starting center fielder
for the Los Angeles Dodgers, sir.
Oh, he is.
Two-time
world series champion.
I couldn't name
one baseball player in the entire league.
Now you got Mookie Betts.
All right.
Get him on the pod, all right, cool.
Let's do listener questions.
Listener questions.
Oh, wait, we have one more thing.
We do?
Oh we do.
One more win of the week.
We do, another win of the week.
"My Octopus Teacher" won the Oscar.
Last night.
Congratulations.
Congratulations team
behind "My Octopus Teacher" and Netflix.
Any thoughts?
Any thoughts for you
on that movie?
I love the movie.
When I saw that they won last night,
I was super excited about it.
And then I found myself feeling bad,
because I was a little bit, what's the right word?
Podcast regret?
A little bit.
Like maybe a little bit too jocular, and-
You were a little hard on the narrator,
or the main guy.
Right, well, as I recall,
I haven't gone back and listened to it,
but we were celebrating the movie,
but I also said, listen,
the sort of elephant in the room is that this guy,
he's struggling with his mental wellbeing.
And I was curious about how that worked
with his relationship with his son
when he starts putting pictures up of,
he sort of puts the serial killer board up
of like all the photos.
And I was like, "What does his son
think when he's doing that?"
I didn't call it that.
And I was-
I thought it was just like
how he organized his art.
I was just having a fun, light-hearted moment.
And I forget that a lot of people watch and listen to this.
And we got an email from his wife?
Yes, his wife.
The producer of the show.
She was very happy that we spoke highly of the movie,
and then I felt really bad.
No, but she actually said something
that I don't think we brought up in the podcast
is that she said she actually does swim with him.
'Cause there was some-
I was very happy
to hear that.
Speculation.
Like his son, towards the end,
his son gets in the water with them.
But now his wife also swims with the group.
And she at first didn't want to,
'cause she was kind of scared in the cold and all that.
And then she got in there and she's one of the regulars.
Right, so that was a really nice email to get.
It was.
And congratulations
to all of them, well-deserved.
Well-deserved, great movie, beautiful movie.
All right, listener questions.
Listener questions.
This is Steven from Charleston, South Carolina.
Hey Rich.
This is Steven Jackson calling in
from Charleston, South Carolina.
Just calling in with a question
about what to do when you feel
like you've hit a wall motivation-wise?
So I signed up for the 4x4x48,
and just feeling pumped after doing
a couple of events before that,
that my ultra running journey
was just on an upward momentum,
and trained really well for the 4x4 and did really well.
But afterwards, I feel like I have just hit a wall
with motivation to keep going,
and keep training for the next thing.
So yeah, in your experience and Adam's experience,
what are some tips to overcome that little bit of plateau
or valley after a big event like that and get back
on the road, feeling good and feeling motivated?
So yeah, man, thanks so much for all you guys do.
Love the pod, the books.
I've been a follower now for two years or so,
and hugely inspirational.
Thank you for impacting so many people, including myself.
So yeah, man, thanks, bye.
Have you been to Charleston?
I have not.
I've been to Savannah,
which is like Charleston, Jr.
Charleston is such a cool place.
They should have a swimrun there.
It would be a great
place to-
Do they not?
I don't know.
They should-
Not that I'm aware of.
They should have one.
It's such a cool city
and there's so much water surrounding it
that you could like run down these historic streets-
That'd be amazing.
And then jump in the water,
and I don't know, I think it would be cool.
It'd be amazing.
Steven, thank you for your question.
Listen, post-race blues is a normal response.
Any athlete who's been in the game
for any period of time has peaks and valleys,
you hit plateaus, et cetera.
So I think you're, first of all,
it's okay that you feel that way.
Every athlete has gone through that.
It's not abnormal.
So I wouldn't beat yourself up for being in that spot.
And not only is it okay for you to take a break,
I would advise taking a break.
You can't just power through race
after race after race after race
and it's just this endless upward trajectory.
It doesn't work that way.
You have to build in periods of rest, periods of recovery.
And that kind of mentality should apply to how you plan out
not just your training blocks week by week,
but also day by day and year by year.
These things are seasonal, right?
And you can't, if longevity is an aim or a goal,
you can't just hammer incessantly.
You've got to build this into your program.
And now that you've had a taste of this,
hopefully, you can understand why this is so important.
At the same time, you don't wanna be that guy
who's rubberbanding in and out of shape,
gaining weight, losing weight.
To some extent, that's okay,
but you don't wanna get too far out of it
that when you get back into it,
you have this very long period of trying to lose
a bunch of extra weight and get into shape.
You wanna stay in contact with your fitness,
so you never wanna move too far away from it,
because it's so much easier to stay in shape
than it is to get totally out of shape
and then spend all your time trying to get back in shape.
And that way, you never feel
like you're actually making progress.
So a couple suggestions that maybe might be helpful for you.
First of all, mix up your training.
And you can do this by cycling it seasonally,
like I mentioned.
Try different things.
If you're running all the time,
get on a bike or get in the water,
go to a yoga class or hit the weight,
or do something else that breaks up
the monotony of just running all the time,
I think is important.
And you got to keep it fun and not so serious.
If you're always in this performance mindset
of chasing these races and these goals,
it's easy to kind of lapse into this state
where you're taking yourself too seriously.
And every minute, you're focused on your training.
And you're gonna burn out.
So you've got to find the joy in all of it.
And I think if you can connect with that,
that will build some longevity
into this journey that you're on.
So again, mixing in some strengths,
some cross-training, other aerobic activities.
Summer's coming up in Charleston.
I'm sure there's things you can do on a boat.
I don't know what goes on there.
Steven, there is a swimrun challenge in June.
There you go.
I don't know What his deal is with swimming,
but maybe he can get into that.
I also think, and this is direct
from the creator of the 4x4x48, David Goggins himself.
It's important to stop over-indexing on motivation,
because motivation is an unreliable motivator.
It really is.
We tend to think, well, I'm not motivated, so I won't do it.
It's very fickle, it's very temporal,
and it shouldn't provide the foundation of your why.
So instead, I always tell people to think
more about it in the context of the values
that you're trying to prioritize.
So instead of saying I don't feel motivated,
the idea would be to say I am an athlete,
or I am somebody who does hard things.
To create identity around it,
as opposed to this fluctuating emotional state
that you can't really create for yourself.
And I think if you can contextualize
what you're doing in that manner,
you'll create a more sustainable fuel for yourself.
I also think that you need to ask yourself
if you're training simply to get a result,
to say you did it, or you cross that finish line,
or you hit that PR,
or are you training because it does bring you joy?
It's an expression of who you are.
Because if you think of yourself as an athlete
or somebody who does hard things,
then you understand that we don't train
when we're motivated to do so,
we train because this is who we are and what we do.
I like it.
That's all really good.
I would just add, or just not even add,
but just emphasize what you said.
I think David would tell you,
if your brain is saying I don't wanna do it,
then you flip that right away and say
if that's what he hears, he's right out the door.
If he hears, I don't wanna
fucking do this shit,
That's the muscle.
He's like, that means you have to go do it,
and you just force yourself to do it.
And it does take time, like you say.
It's the same thing you're saying.
Telling yourself you're an athlete
or I'm someone who does hard things
is the same thing as saying,
well, I don't wanna do it today.
Oh, that means I have to do it today.
So it's just however you want to do it,
you're training the brain to flip it.
And I think he'd say that.
And the other thing I would say
is I'm big believer in cross-training,
just like you said, I think it really does help.
It brings the fun into it.
So whether it's swimming or riding a bike or whatever it is.
And then the zone two training.
Maybe he's running too hard.
Zone two, I found I enjoy running
in a way that I never enjoyed it before.
Kinda takes the pressure off.
You can feel tired and it's late in the day,
but you're like, well, it's just a zone two run.
You don't have to sweat it.
Don't be fixated on your garment
and all the kind of devices
and hold yourself to some standard
that every time you go out to train,
you've got to be better and faster
than you were the day before.
Right, if you just decide,
I'm gonna lay back and do an hour of zone two,
then you still do get a sweat.
You still do burn calories.
You still do get some positive benefits.
When you're going on heart rate, too,
you're not measuring yourself against a pace
where then you either feel bad or good about yourself,
dictated by that.
You're just training where you're at.
You're not training where you think you should be
or where you were last year at this time.
Train where you're at.
Love it, good one.
Great question.
I should have prefaced this.
All these questions are kind of run-oriented,
which is good.
I'm starting to try to curate this moment.
No finswimming questions today?
No, we've had enough mermen-
I'm training world championships in finswimming, Rich.
Enough merman talk for one day.
You guys were like the OG Instagram roommates.
Yeah, I don't know.
There was barely an internet back then.
You were the OG internet mermen.
All right, Casey from Illinois.
Hello, Rich and Adam, this is Casey from Illinois.
And I am running the Chicago Marathon
for the first time in October.
And I'm just wondering if you've had
any after-race, after-run tips.
And thank you for all you do.
I love the podcast and the books, thank you.
Thanks, Casey.
Did he say after-race, after-run?
I thought it was just any race than an after-run tips,
but let's just go with what you got.
Right, 'cause I saw this typed out
before I listened to it,
and now I'm wondering whether I need to rethink this.
But I'm gonna answer it the way
that I feel like answering it.
There you go.
Hopefully, this is helpful to Casey.
First of all, with respect to race tips,
there's this maxim that you shouldn't do anything
on race day that you didn't do in training.
Race day is not the time to test out
a fancy new pair of shoes or a new pacing strategy
or some kind of new nutrition protocol
or some gel that you've never tried before.
Training is all about testing, testing, testing
so that by the time you reach your race,
you already know exactly what you're doing.
The race is merely the execution
of what you've already done.
So if you've trained properly and you visualized it,
then it just becomes about showing up, enjoying yourself,
and celebrating the journey that got you there.
So having fun, enjoying it I think is super important.
The whole idea of running a marathon
is to have a positive experience.
It's gonna hurt of course,
but if and when you feel like it's all
falling apart and you feel terrible,
you should also know that that isn't necessarily
a predictor of anything because in a long race,
things change, you can feel terrible,
then you'll feel good, then you'll feel terrible again.
And you learn to just keep going no matter what.
And with that, to adapt to any unforeseen variables
that get thrown in your direction.
A lot of times, athletes, they visualize,
they train and they're very attached
to the race unfolding in a very specific way.
And the minute something goes wrong,
like you step in a puddle and suddenly your foot's all wet,
or I don't know, somebody bumps you when you fall down,
anything unforeseen can throw somebody off their mental game
and they have a hard time kind of getting back into it.
So I think sort of understanding
that there's gonna be variables that get thrown in your way
and learning how to be resilient with those
is super important and something to prepare
mentally and physically for in your training.
In addition, on race day, you should know
what your strategy is and you should implement that.
Meaning, run your race,
not the race that the person next to you is running.
It's very easy, especially when there's a lot of people
around you and people are passing you
that you can get caught up in what others are doing.
And it takes a certain level of confidence
and discipline to not let any of that
impact your plan that you've set for yourself.
So sticking to your plan is key.
And that also means that on race day,
you're gonna have all this extra energy.
You're gonna be very excited.
There's gonna be a lot of crowd and whatever.
And if you find yourself feeling like,
you're five miles in and you feel amazing,
a lot of athletes throw their race plan out the window
and just start speeding up 'cause they feel great
only to like explode at mile 18.
So if you feel amazing, resist that urge
to go faster and stick to your plan.
In terms of after race, which I think is really
the core of what Casey wants answers to.
I think after your race, it's important to do
an inventory of what went right and what went wrong.
You can write it out in a journal, just in freehand,
everything that that you thought about,
every emotional experience, what it felt like physically,
where it went to plan, where it didn't go to plan.
You can mine the data.
And all of that is an ample opportunity
to learn from the experience that you just had.
But the important thing is in the aftermath of the race,
have fun, go to the Beer Garden, whatever, enjoy yourself,
make sure you hydrate, fuel up, stay warm, ice your legs.
I think active recovery in the days
that follow is super important.
If it's your first marathon,
you're gonna be unbelievably stiff
and have trouble going up and down stairs
or even walking around.
But you've got to, you shouldn't just lay in bed.
You should get up and move and go on walks
and try to get the blood flowing in a low-grade way.
And that'll help flush out all the lactic acid
and help you recover a little bit more quickly.
But there's no need to go running for,
I don't know, a week or 10 days or something like that.
Allow your body to heal.
And I think another mistake a lot of athletes make
is they wanna get right back into it too quickly.
And they underestimate just how much their body
gets beat up in running something like a marathon.
So giving your body the space and the time
to repair itself takes longer than you might imagine.
And providing that opportunity
for yourself I think is important.
Go to the Beer Garden.
Advice I never thought I'd hear Rich Roll deliver on.
I'm not going to the Beer,
well, I can go to the Beer Garden,
I'm not gonna drink the beer,
but he can drink the beer if that's what he wants to do.
I always enter any sort of race with one plan.
Just don't come in last.
Why, well, what's wrong with that?
What's wrong with coming in last?
The lanterne rouge?
I'm sure as I age, I will even let that go. (laughs)
This is the extent of your competitive fire.
Don't come in last.
The extent of my egotism.
I would suggest not even thinking about that at all,
because that means that you're gauging
your performance off of other people.
I know, it's true.
You should just think about executing
your race the way that you trained for.
And I'm glad we didn't get into my shaming
of not wearing goggles when I swim.
We'll have to do that another time.
Yeah, oh, that's right, we didn't even talk about that.
So Adam and I, we'll quickly recap this
before the final question.
I'm talking to Adam on the phone the other night
and he's telling me about how his face mask is big.
What do you call?
I don't even know you-
I took three waves on the head
on my way in from my last swim, which was fun.
I enjoyed getting thrashed and ragdolled,
because it was not that big a surf,
but I did get messed up and I lost my mask.
I wear a mask.
He wears a mask.
So I just can't, I'm like, listen, buddy, all right,
as somebody who's competed in swimrun competitions,
from an etiquette perspective,
a real swimmer would never wear a face mask.
I'm a breaker of etiquette.
So get on the goggles and dispatch this.
It's good that it got lost.
It's time, all right.
It's embarrassing to go swimming with you in the ocean
and you're wearing a face mask.
You are not the Octopus Teacher.
Wait.
You are a swimrun athlete.
No, no, no, no, let me push back just for a second.
I wear a Sphera mask
by Aqua Sphere.
I don't care.
What are you talking about?
Well, the Sphera mask
was designed for open water swimmers.
Listen, Aqua Sphere also makes goggles-
They do.
For open water swimming.
But I would highly suggest the FINIS line of goggles-
FINIS.
Including the smart goggle.
It might interest you.
Can I interest you in a smart goggle?
Yeah, no more mask, dude, come on.
What are we doing here?
I promise.
(laughs) All right, let's finish this.
Here we go, one last question from a couple
of badass adventurers in the Great North.
Hi, Rich and Adam, this is Asha and Savannah.
We are two girls from Kelowna, British Columbia, Canada,
and we have decided to run 500 kilometers barefoot,
starting this run on June 21st, 2021.
So we're one month into training
and have just a few left,
which is why as plant-based vegans,
we're hoping to link arms with you
to receive the proper nutritional wisdom
to make those 500 kilometers a success.
Rich, your journey to your first ultra
gave us the confidence that we are capable of this feat.
We know we can do this.
So call us anytime.
And as we like to say, keep rolling on.
Awesome.
Ciao.
All right, first of all, a couple things.
I feel like this is much more about like,
"Hey, Rich, will you call us?"
than it is a legitimate interest
in me answering this question.
No, but this is
you calling them-
But it's awesome.
Asha and Savannah.
Were they both talking back and forth?
It seemed like, it seemed like it.
All right, I love these women, this is awesome.
500 kilometers barefoot.
I like how they have only been training a month,
and there's only like two months left
or less than two months before they're gonna do this.
So that's amazing.
I like that they're plant-based vegans,
and I'd be happy to link arms with them.
Maybe I should call them at some point.
So wind in your sails, this is very cool.
I wanna know more about this adventure.
Are they running on pavement, I suppose?
Or trails.
What exactly
is going on here?
Do they have roads in Kelowna, British Columbia?
I think they do, right?
That's a terrible thing to say.
I think they have roads (laughs).
Do they pave the roads up there?
That's pretty far north.
I'm just kidding.
Is it?
I don't know.
You guys are awesome.
Very cool.
I'm here to support you 100%.
And although I'm not sure you really need any advice,
'cause I don't know that that's what this is about,
I think nutrition is very personal.
So specifics I don't think
are gonna be super helpful to you guys.
Like I said in the answer to the previous question,
test, test, test, test all this stuff out.
You guys have plenty of time to work out
your nutrition regimen in the lead up to this adventure.
So when you start, you should know
exactly what works for you and what doesn't.
If you wanna stay on the whole food, tip,
what's worked for me and what has worked
for many other people are things like sweet potatoes,
which are easily digestible
when you're running at a low pace.
They kind of work like nature's gels.
Dates are great, almond butter is great,
coconut water for hydration.
I think you need to figure out some estimate
of how many calories you're burning per hour.
And then from that, figure out how many calories
you can reasonably take in on an hourly basis
to make sure that you're replenishing yourself
as much as possible without upsetting your stomach.
And the upset stomach thing is the big thing, right?
When you're testing, you have to almost overdo it
to figure out where that line is and which foods
your body is able to digest better than others
to figure out what's gonna work for you.
And also, understanding that no matter what you do,
when you're tackling an adventure like this,
500 kilometers barefoot,
you are very quickly gonna go into a caloric deficit.
You're not gonna be able to eat
that much when you're running.
When you're cycling, it's a little bit easier,
but you're always gonna be coming from the rear
in terms of meeting your body's caloric needs,
which means it's really important
that you figure out a schedule
so that you're taking in as much as you can,
like I said, without upsetting your stomach,
even when you're not hungry.
There'll be moments where you're like, I'm not eating.
And you need a crew member who's gonna say,
we knew you were going say that,
but you have to eat right now,
because you're not eating for that moment,
you're eating for the following day.
So even though if you feel great
and you don't wanna put anything in your stomach,
you have to understand that's gonna impair
your body's ability to repair itself and come back
the next day and the next day and the next day.
So super important to stay on top of it.
If you're open to some performance nutrition products,
I can shout out a couple podcast sponsors.
UCAN for slow carbs, they're great.
It's very easily digestible.
You can put a ton of calories
in a water bottle and just sip it.
And that's been very helpful, especially for something like-
Would you suggest regular,
every 30 minutes I'm gonna have a sip,
every hour I'm gonna have food.
Yeah, it could be, everybody's different.
Some people, every 20 minutes,
it's 50 calories or something like that.
So you just create this slow drip.
What you don't wanna do is spike
your blood sugar and then have a crash.
That's what you're trying to avoid.
So the kind of slow carb, what would you call it?
The carbohydrates that are in something like UCAN
are designed to not spike that blood sugar,
but to kind of give you a slow drip of energy,
which is exactly what you're looking for.
For electrolytes, coconut water's great,
but you really wanna make sure that you're staying
on top of that proper ratio and balance.
So LMNT, another podcast sponsor, they're great for that.
There's no sugar or artificial ingredients in that.
You know.
I love it.
Doing the Goggins thing that it worked for you.
So maybe check those out.
And make sure that when you're getting those rest periods,
the recovery in between, that you're doing everything
in your power to not just replenish those calories,
but repair your body for the next day.
So ice baths, if that's possible,
if you don't have a Theragun.
I'm just shouting out all the sponsors.
Theragun-
You are.
But these are products that work and are helpful.
And to make sure that you
are getting the sleep that you need,
that's the most powerful recovery enhancement.
It looks like Kelowna is on a fingerling lake.
Did you look at the map?
Just east of Vancouver,
where it's like the British Columbia wine country.
You know how there's wine country up there.
So I think that's where it looks like.
And so it-
Depends on the route, right,
but if they're near the lake, maybe they can get-
Yeah, if there's no ice bath,
just jump in that lake for a while.
But I don't know if they're doing this,
do they have a crew?
Are they being supported?
Is there a van?
Are they just going straight through?
Are they gonna sleep?
Lots of questions, so many questions.
And I have one other question.
How do you-
I feel like
they did that on purpose, so then now I have to call them.
Yes, and how do you care
for the bare feet when you're taking breaks?
I don't know, they gotta call Tony Riddle.
I have no experience with that, I really don't know,
but that's Tony Riddle's department.
All right, anyway, it was a wonderful question.
You guys are amazing.
And we're looking forward to hearing
more about your incredible run.
Sending you love and strength.
We are.
All right,
I think we did it.
We done did it.
Thus concludes another successful episode of "Roll On."
I deem it a success.
I think it is.
Yeah.
Can I fact check a couple of things?
Sure.
One, point of information,
Mookie plays the outfield,
mostly in right field, not center field.
So that's supposed to make me care about baseball?
Listen, he's plant-based
and he's one of the best players in the league.
That's awesome, cool.
Just like Chris Paul,
plant-based, great basketball player.
And then the other thing is you asked me
if it was me who'd become plant-based.
I'm 98% plant-based.
What's with this 2%?
What is with the 2%?
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm a 2% omnivore.
Listen, Brogan is lining up to take your seat.
(laughs) I'm not helping myself.
So get on board.
Brogan, don't use that against me.
All right, is that all
the fact checking we're doing today?
That's all the fact checking.
I'm gonna fact check you
on your swimming face mask situation.
We're gonna talk
about that next time.
I'm gonna bring it in.
I just (laughs)-
Burn that thing.
All right, we're done.
I feel good, you feel good?
I feel great.
Awesome.
Hey, it's good to be back.
It is good to be back.
Yeah, right?
Follow Adam @adamskolnick,
I'm @richroll on all this stuff.
Leave us a message, 424 235-4626.
To check out links to everything we talked about today,
including the stuff about all the products and,
I don't know, we talked about a lot of stuff,
Ezra Klein's article, check out the show notes
on the episode page at richroll.com.
There's also a link to that in the description below
if you're watching on YouTube.
Please subscribe to us, we would really appreciate it,
on YouTube, Apple, Spotify, all this stuff.
And that's it.
We're gonna be back here in two weeks.
We had a week off, so a lot of energy.
Yeah, was I too much?
No, it was good.
Yeah.
We made a symphony.
Symphony of conversation.
More music to come next time.
Appreciate all of you.
Thank you for tuning in and listening.
I don't take your attention for granted.
And I do not produce this show alone.
Certainly, Adam Skolnick sitting across from me
played a small part in today. (laughs)
Thank you, sir.
And of course, Jason Camiolo
for audio engineering production,
show notes, interstitial music,
all kinds of behind the scenes stuff
for which he does not receive enough credit.
Blake Curtis, who created
the video version of today's podcast.
I was in here Sunday afternoon.
Blake was in here putting the finishing touches
on the Jeremiah Ellison episode, burning the weekend hours.
If you haven't checked it out,
you should watch it on YouTube,
'cause we have all this B-roll
from the square-
Okay, I watched the rest
on YouTube.
Minneapolis.
Yeah, it's really nice.
He did a great job with the edit as he always does.
Jessica Miranda for graphics.
Davy Greenberg, Minneapolis native.
Oh.
Couldn't make the trip,
yeah, unfortunately, 'cause he was on vacation,
but he's here today to shoot some amazing portraits.
Georgia Whaley for copywriting.
DK for advertiser relationships.
And theme music, as always by Tyler,
Trapper, and Hari who are in the process
of trying to name their band.
You mean Tres Primos?
Tres Primos, yeah, we'll see, I don't know.
I don't think that's gonna make it.
Maybe, I really wanna redo this theme music.
I think it's time.
I think the audience would rebel or revolt.
Can we use one of their new songs?
I don't mind the music,
'cause people have kind of an attachment to it now,
but I don't like how I say, "The Rich Roll Podcast."
Like, come on, man, we could do better, can't we?
Listen, can Brogan and I do an acapella number?
I would welcome that.
Let's make that happen.
Jason could write a little music for that.
Jason.
We'll do it.
Let's do it.
All right,
thanks for the love, you guys.
See you back here in a couple days
with another episode notes from Minneapolis.
To be continued until then.
Peace, plants.
Namaste.